i don't want to embarrass you you're uh
extremely attractive woman i'm guessing
that uh growing up you were you just
must have been extremely popular you
were in the popular girls group weren't
you um i was for a split second but i
have to say it didn't start that way i
started a group called pig which stood
for the popular in group and we had
tactics of how to make it into the
popular group right um so it was a lot
of you had to swear a lot um and you had
to dye your hair platinum blonde which i
did very like christina aguilera coming
over video
um yeah
you dyed your hair and immediately you
were in the in group yeah kind of like
one of the popular girls was like you
she brought me over and she was like
well we had a meeting and we decided
that you are now allowed into the
popular group i ended up deciding that i
would be known as the girl who could
throw parties and i threw some kind of
awesome abandoned house parties when you
say abandoned house parties that mean
that you would go and find an abandoned
house and just say we're partying here
like how does that work um i don't think
she forced people off their lives i did
get out of here oh maybe she did she's
like we're partying here
[Laughter]
it's possible andy
so tell me how this worked the abandoned
house party well my dad he's kind of a
real estate investor so he would buy
these properties and then knock them
down and make apartments so basically
they would be empty for a while before
they knocked it down before they knocked
it down so um i said to my dad oh you
know it's the end of the year i just
want to have a little you know girls tea
party um can i have the key to the house
um and i ended up getting this key and
then i wrote out like cut to 16 year old
girls like writing out flyers which said
bring everybody open house party bring
booze
and we printed out like 500 of these
flyers and just started handing them out
where in south australia just in the
city just to randoms you handed out
invitations to people all over the city
yeah okay so how many people showed up
about three thousand like literally it
was the biggest party australia's ever
seen um the house burnt down
the
yeah
wait a minute let's you can't jump to
that part i know what do you mean the
house burnt down it did it there was a
swat team three fire brigades came the
ambulance came it was all on the news um
what happened was i guess everyone
someone had a fire someone lit the fire
and they they um set our school bags on
fire so we all brought our school bags
we're gonna crash the night there and
they just lit fire to the school bags
and i heard one person say demolition
party
and then they started throwing cans and
all the windows smashed and then they
set it on fire australians are crazy i
mean
you have a party and you're like well oh
this is great we've got dip we've got
nachos let's set these gym bags on fire
i know i couldn't believe it it was kind
of awful when you say the house burnt
down you mean it just burnt to the
ground pretty much like during i could
see what was happening during the party
all my friends their parents had already
picked them up at this point because it
had gotten out of control and i could
people were stomping on the stairs to
collapse them then one guy grabbed the
only piece of furniture in the house
which is a piano and pushed and he
literally went wee
and pushed the piano down the stairs and
then i see these guys lighting fires i
mean it was insane okay so then your dad
gets the call he yeah your daughter had
a party for 3 000 people and burnt your
house to the ground yeah how did that go
over um well he didn't actually know he
didn't find out i mean the party went
through until like 7am the next morning
so first thing in the morning i woke up
and i drove straight to his work
and i was like um i really need to speak
to my dad i need a meeting this is
really insane
so dad comes in and his face is just
ashen and i was like i have something
really important to tell you it's really
disappointing and dad's like you're
pregnant
and
is he petting a koala this whole time
[Music]
oh my golly what is that noise though
that doesn't sound like a collapsible
break i'm not from adelaide i don't know
what in the koala sounds like
i just called it a koala
corner so he said so he thought you were
pregnant he thought i was pregnant and i
was like ew dad no
no i just burnt down the house that you
were gonna knock down anyway
um and i was like you don't have to pay
for it to get demolished now
um and then he he just was kind of cool
about it he was glad i wasn't pregnant
he's on tranquilizers i think
i know i should have been here i mean
he's like well all right then he's like
as long as you're not pregnant